when you're 13 years old and every
teacher you have tells you that you're
going to be a loser and a garbage man I
don't know feel bad like I'm so pissed
that they would always on garbage
men I feel like that's such a job I
respect so much but that was the hot
thing in the 80s you're gonna be a
garbage man I was like I was actually
kind of Pumped I'm like oh I can
get stuff for free instead of the garage
sales and flip it you know I think
that's why I'm unstoppable now because
at 11 12 13 14 every grown-up I knew
told me I was going to be a loser while
my mother told me I wasn't and the world
told me I wasn't I was selling lemonade
shoveling snow selling baseball cards
flipping stuff at garage sales and I was
great at it the market told me I was
great my mom told me I was great because
I was a nice person and here I am 46
years later a nice businessman and built
a personal brand because I can deal with
people on me because they've
been on me of course people
struggle putting themselves out there
they grew up as A and B students haven't
had that emotional adversity yet